[Music]
I have so many friends who want to buy
books and want to learn the problem is
they buy a book they start it they get
two or three chapters in and then they
stop reading and then they feel bad that
they've stopped reading they don't pick
up another book because they know they
want to finish this book we've been
taught that once we start something we
have to finish it and I think that so
often we view books as this linear thing
whereas I think a different view of
books is what information do I need out
of this book right now is that an
entertainment read do I need to read
from start to finish is it a read where
I'm comparing different views on the
similar problem especially across
nonfiction right am i my comparing and
contrasting two or three different
authors argumentation or authors views
on a particular angle to a subject which
case I might not need to read the whole
book I just need to read a chapter but
then I've gotten everything out of that
book but books are there to serve you
right you own the book the book is your
property it's your mental property it's
your physical property and you can do
with it what you want you don't have to
feel bad about putting down a book it's
the author's job to pull you into the
book it's your job to extract what you
need out of the book and I think that
extracting what you need you can just
read the table of contents read the
introduction maybe you read the
conclusion skim a little bit and is this
a book that I want to read in its
entirety in most of the time the answer
is going to be no a lot of the books
that are published today could easily be
20 to 40 pages and you would get
everything that you need out of that
book so it's a big waste of time to read
it cover-to-cover but if you want to
extract the general principles from the
book or it's sort of like argumentation
that the author's making you don't need
to read every little anecdote that's put
in there or every story of Billy and Bob
you just need to know like what is the
framework for this argumentation do I
agree with it don't I agree with it do I
have to make a decision on whether I
agree with it or not does a different
author have a contrasting view that I
want to learn about or is this something
that I'm just reading for general
knowledge I might not put into practice
or if you think about skill development
right which is a common reason that most
of us read will think of I want to learn
about leadership
and we'll think of this very big broad
category whereas it's usually much more
beneficial from a learning perspective
to narrow down the aspect of leadership
I want to talk about leading a small
team for the first time I want to talk
about team meetings I want to talk about
what are they like break down what it
means to be a leader and then hone in on
those particular categories pick up a
whole bunch of leadership books but then
read just for those specific categories
across the books if you're reading for
knowledge that's going to give you a
much better outcome than sort of picking
up one of these books and reading it
cover-to-cover
because it's going to be hard to put it
into practice it's going to be hard to
compare different contrasting views on
the subject it's gonna be harder to
determine what works for you and
ultimately that's why you're reading you
want to figure out what works for you
and that's not always what somebody else
says a lot of what books cover is here's
what worked for me and what worked for
me in this particular ecosystem this
particular point in time with this
particular team that may or may not work
for you your job is to sort of
understand to what extent does that
carry over to what I'm doing and to what
extent do I have to change that and does
it work for me and if it doesn't how am
I going to get the feedback that I need
so that I can learn from that and then
adapt my process so that it does work
[Music]